but if you're just a YouTuber asking
people to give you money there needs to
be full Financial disclosure from people
like Ali dawa from all of these people
who are asking you to give them money
well I need to know what your income is
what you're using that money for and
where it's coming from yeah I can show
you my bank accounts I've got three bank
accounts what personal account in a
Barclays I've got a business account and
I've got another bank account in Halifax
and I will put you all the balances
right now in front of you and while I
talk screenshots today
just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years what
is one thing that they would carry with
them the Quran why because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets brothers and sisters imagine you
have a app the qurani app which not only
shows you how much rewards you get but
reminds you to read the Quran gives you
reminders download the Quran up now and
let it testify for you on your makayama
that you read it wherever you was
brothers and sisters and dear friends
I'm going to get straight into this
topic inshallah this brother here I've
seen a couple of his videos he came out
of nowhere a couple of weeks ago and
alhamdulillah he's doing I mean really
interesting you know he's the way he's
replying to certain answers contentions
doubts that are thrown to him and
anytime in the Dao scene I see somebody
coming and aiding the course I'm happy
when Miami job came into the scene uh
you know first to me it was a breath of
fresh air because he tackles issues that
I can't tackle he goes to areas I can't
go to and alhamdul he puts so much hard
work into and many people do not like
him so to me it's a pleasure and honor
to have somebody who is on the scene now
what upsets me is that all of a sudden
about a week ago I just started seeing
this very brother which we can watch the
videos for ourselves now in a minute we
can watch it starting in directing
people and I'm just like why are you
ruin it like why I understand don't get
interested if somebody is doing
something that is Haram wrong misusing
what if it may be the funds or whatever
it may be understandable
but all the things that is coming from
his brother is nothing but absolute
accusations it's a matter of the heart
and it's as if he's talking about the
Unseen here is a video where he's
criticizing I don't know if he got me
confused with Prophet Tower man
um and and he thinks his name is because
I get that a lot you know but people
come and say tomorrow are you Ali man
you know Etc so I don't know if you got
me confused or matter I'm not saying
that he's right about that man but
here's the video watch it for yourself
guys
I'm gonna have to try and make this
quick because I'm very angry to be
honest and disgusted I came across this
thing called the better club and it's
basically some Muslim guys from the UK
who are trying to be sort of uh Andrew
Tate they're all jumping on this
masculinity bandwagon and he reach a
stage where it's time for boys to become
men all about men and you know men being
with men and men and men and men in
masculinity and blah blah blah blah blah
a place for men only it's like a you
know Boys Club a masculinity club and
it's supposedly also about like success
and making you success useful in
materialist terms same time there's a
video on their Tick Tock channel for the
brother Club
where this brother is talking about you
know you don't really need your job you
know you could just quit your job you're
nine to five you know it's getting in
the way of you know your relationship
with Allah
as if work isn't worship because you're
providing for your family but forget
that uh you don't really need your job
you know you could just do start your
own business or some kind of a side
Hustle
who is giving you money
you're showing people literally that
you're living the lifestyle of a
freaking millionaire
and still asking people for money so I
guess that's how you don't need a job
because you can just do the Dao hustle
and tell people you know give to us
because it's like giving feasibility
it's like giving to uh you know a good
cause it's good for spreading Islam and
teaching Islam and stuff like this so
give us money meanwhile you use that
money to live the lifestyle of the Rich
and Famous and to dupe young men who are
inexperienced naive gullible stupid I
mean the whole the whole way that you're
marketing this is specifically to filter
out
anyone with intelligence anyone with
experience anyone who isn't gullible and
naive it's specifically the target naive
stupid inexperienced young men this is
disgusting there needs to be full
Financial disclosure from all of these
YouTube deities who are asking for money
if you have an actual organization
you're in relief work even your a Masjid
or you're supporting Islamic schools or
you know actual projects on the ground
that's one thing even that there should
be Financial disclosure but if you're
just a YouTuber asking people to give
you money there needs to be full
Financial disclosure from people like
from people like Ali dawa from people
like Gabriel Romani from all of these
people who are asking you to give them
money well I need to know what your
income is what you're using that money
for and where it's coming from and what
your expenses are and where that money
is going because if you're living the
High Life
off of money that the Muslims are giving
you
this Haram this is really really
upsetting to me people using Islam for
business it's not even like proper
business it's like conning people
this is absolutely repugnant and
repulsive well guys you saw that in the
video like in the video it's very clear
that he's criticizing the thing that you
know brother Imran he was doing the free
one for the butter crab Etc you know
they changed it they stopped whatever it
may be for that matter their own
teachers advised him no problem okay
they accepted a mistake and we're not
people that were going to nitpick etc
for that matter no problem yeah I wasn't
really fond of it myself it's okay no
problem yeah
now the point here is the following
though now he comes towards the end
mentions myself Daniel Romani
now I know
I know of him Etc I don't agree with
everything he says neither does Hebrew
version I say you know but the point
here is this now you have put a doubt in
people's minds about the tower scene now
I am one of the first people when I hit
the first million subscribers I've done
a video if you if you haven't seen it
because it just shows me that you
haven't seen it if you go watch that
video I have clearly and categorically
said point I want to come to people have
turned that one like it's their dad's
business like it's their dad's money
there are people who feel entitled and
I'm not giving names to anybody
dawa is not your dad's it doesn't belong
to you it's a manner given by Allah to
you you cannot act and behave we hear
stories of people coming to give speech
talks and charging thousands of pounds
they've been asking I want me and my one
and my two wives to be thrown out in
business class
who the hell do you think you are who
the hell do you think you are this isn't
a manner for you to serve the Deen this
isn't a manner for you to serve the
community that gawah is being turned
into a business like a corporation as if
it's somebody's like as if it's their
dad's business I've been talking about
this for a very long time now I'm not
blaming anybody all I'm saying is that
myself personally and I make it very
honest yeah I can show you my bank
accounts I've got three bank accounts
what personal account in a Barclays I've
got a business account and I've got
another bank account in Halifax and I
will put you all the balances right now
in front of you and while I talk
screenshots today today I took a
screenshots so you can see and the one
that has two thousand and seven pounds
in it I've got my rent coming 1200
pounds so that's going to be deducted as
well yeah so the point is what that this
accusation that we are there for the
money and the fame Allah is my witness
if I want I can make quota of a million
pounds a year
I can I can have the ability you know
turn on my Super Chat my patreon the pay
part and this that Etc I choose not to
for my personal reasons and I'm not
seeing anybody that has patreon or
PayPal or Super Chat for that matter
I've got bad intentions this is a Crux
of the matter this product is having
sadly and I just want to advise them
because I don't know much about him but
please brother stop because Allah says
in the Quran all you who believe avoid
much negative assumptions indeed some
assumptions is a sin and do not spy and
backbot each other would one like to eat
the Flesh of his brothers dead brother
so the point is this for what evidence
do you have to claim people like myself
or anyone for that matter is misusing
the funds and please can you tell me
when have I ever asked for funds for
myself to carry on my tower when when we
raise for Salam 300 000 pounds nearly
it's a charity
and off that 300 000 pounds not a single
penny I'll repeat again not a single
penny has gone into my pocket why
because I am a volunteer in that
organization yeah I do not get a single
penny for the work that I do in the
organization none and I choose to do
that and this doesn't mean I'm better
than other people or I'm more Pious so
this attitude of thinking that just
because I don't charge none of them's in
charge my arguments saying don't make a
living out of a doubt which there is
nothing wrong as long as you are not
like oh five thousand pounds ten
thousand pounds three times but no
everyone needs a decent amount whatever
that is for that matter to provide for
their family and get along though I
don't eat grass they don't they're not
gonna eat gross let's be real yes and
it's exact islamically allowed so
therefore and we know the evidence from
the Quran those who collect zakah they
are even eligible to have something
because that's their job so the point is
what yes he's right about people
misusing the tower where he's right
about people who are charging
extravagance oh fly me out business
class and my wife business class and I I
want two thousand pounds per talk 100
I'm 100 with him in this but to come and
give people by name where you have no
single evidence a key and you are
slandering this is a slander you've
mentioned be my my name you need to come
out and apologize yes because you have
now slandered myself Gabriel Romani
Daniel hakikachu you are slandering
these brothers as if all we're doing is
can you please show me evidence that
I've come out and said give me funds I
need money don't need to me so I can
carry my tawa tell me when I used to do
Uber for a living I used to drive a
Toyota Prius that wasn't even owned by
me this house that I'm living on my left
is the kitchen on my right is my living
room right in front of me the toilet and
over there is my bedroom where me my
wife and my three kids sleeping yes okay
so before you do that please feel Allah
that it is a big oppression no need that
forget myself you are astonishing the
dialer scene as if we are all money
making hungry you know how much more
rich I can get fear Allah
fear Allah what I'm gonna say is that
they because for you to recklessly
recklessly mention these things you are
a damaging thousand and if you have this
attitude of thinking the argument said
let's suppose you don't make anything
from YouTube which is not there is
nothing wrong I didn't monetize my
YouTube channel for four to five years
until we got to fatwa and YouTube
allowed us to block ads we are not Money
Motivated or money hungry individuals we
want to make the Kalam of Allah and I
will taken off by the Quran if you doubt
that yeah so therefore my brother please
be careful to your tongue the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said and I'll
end on this that Muslim is the one the
best Muslim is the one that his tongue
and his hands are free from oppressing
another a Muslim be very careful because
in this matter you have oppressed myself
and whoever is for that matter yes you
have made an assumption about us so I
asked you to rectify it please and
please stop accusing Brothers
alhamdulillah we try our best to help
individuals and believe me I have Rich
multi millionaires that come to me and
say do you need funding and I say I
don't need a single penny I don't want
nothing if you want to help the
organization there yes problem is doing
amazing work I error we do amazing work
sapiens donate to them I am good so
please I ask you to refrain from this my
brother since you mentioned by name I am
just making scarification I do not know
your your name your nutrition I don't
know may Allah bless your work carry on
I benefit from it but it is sad to see
that this is coming out your mouth and
please be careful what like the hack of
people is very very severe the seller
would say you would rather stand in
front of Allah with 70 sins between us
and him rather than one sin that will
wrong somebody so please my brother
Allah please acknowledge this and I have
always always said this before this is a
real phenomena people are taking the
dawa and turning into a money-making
business yes charging ridiculous amounts
of working with Charities 20 25 Cuts
they get may Allah forgive us that's
what I'm gonna say and I'm not saying
that thing is Haram I'm just saying your
consciousness
and I hope inshallah he rectifies this
um accusations till next time